the growing chaos around us I thought
well wondering what I could do and I
thought maybe I could give the symbolic
structure of how and why we do human
eyes aspects of humanity so my hope in
showing this pattern to you is that our
capacity to dehumanize to demonize be
seen for what it is not a question of
sides not what our enemies do but
something which is a deep and integral
part of what we could call it say our
fallen cells so the key to this like the
key to so much can be found in our
stories and when looking for a pattern
it's always best to look to Genesis
first and then to move from there to
move towards Christ or usually the
resolution to the pattern is found so I
want to do this as another example of
how this works in general of how these
patterns that keep talking about fit
together but also a way to to address
both sides of a growing and radicalizing
conflict so in the Bible there is a
state of things before the world is
spoken into being this is the primordial
chaos primordial ocean out of which
everything emerges
so this primordial chaos is darkness
it's the impossibility of life in a way
it's before the origin before the logos
begins the ordering process so the word
out of this original emptiness out of
this original in the Bible it's Tohu
Bowl which is this emptiness and void
the word creates and separates so that
the world comes into being so if we skip
further after Adam and Eve fall in the
Garden of Eden they're chased out of the
ordered place the garden with the Tree
of Life in the center
the wall surrounding and protecting it
moving towards the outside was a moving
into death where a progressive chaos
emerged now this progressive chaos can
be seen as as a moving forward in time
towards an end let's say so the
generations obtain advanced after Adam
and Eve those generations became more
and more complex but also more and more
corrupt until we reach the story of the
flood and the flood is a return to that
primordial ocean that primordial chaos
which was there before the beginning we
could say it read before the
manifestation of identity of logos of
the let there be such and such an
identifiable thing there is of course a
strong relationship between logos and
identity naming things being the most
obvious and the most explicit version of
this so anyway so this cosmic form can
be seen in time so also not only as we
we move further in time but as we move
move further away in space things also
start to be more and more chaotic until
we reach the edge of the world and there
you know the traditional representation
of the world that say the kind of
symbolic representation of the world is
that the world is this this giant island
and then on the edge of the world is
this eternally flowing ocean which is
the same ocean if you will the same
primordial ocean as what was there
before the beginning of the world and in
that note in that ocean is the the Sun
penetrable chaos where you know that
where all the the sea serpents and all
the monsters are now there's also an
individual vision of this structure
which echoes the cosmic one
so as human beings as we move forward in
time we're also coming closer and closer
to our personal death as the end of that
movement and on the edge of the human
being itself we find you know hair and
nails and a layer of dead skin which is
the spatial equivalent if you will of
the temporal movement towards death okay
so in the Bible it's an in the Church
Fathers this is represented as what's
called the garments of skin this is a
layer of death of animal skins which God
placed around us like a kind of vaccine
a layer of death to protect us from
death so notice how what is placed
around our periphery okay
this place as the edge of our being is
what came before Allah before us in the
order of creation God created all the
animals and then created Adam so in a
way it's it's analogical to those
primordial waters which are both before
the world in terms of time but also on
the edge of the world surrounding the
world okay okay so now one last analogy
to sense this for you is that in the
tradition of the church in the tradition
in the Christian tradition we also have
as individuals we also have these
desires we have this multiplicity of
desire which is also in a way the edge
of our being these competing desires
which fight for our attention you know
fighting even amongst themselves and
these desires must be mastered or
transformed so that they don't lead us
away from our heart from our own center
of consciousness and give us a way to be
devoured by these animal passions let's
call them so what I want you to mostly
get from from that from now is that in
this pattern death and chaos are
discernible in what could be found
before
the origin of order which is identity so
my the before my origin as a human but
also before the garden before the city
before the country before this before
our civilization okay but at the same
time death and chaos which is also
animality danger and wild desires also
lie at the edge at the edge and the end
of the order with which I identify okay
so in terms of the preceding chaos on a
cosmic level you know that's why for
example in Greek mythology the Titans
were there before the gods of Olympus
and in many culture than in many
mythological stories there's a
generation of giant monsters which exist
before the arrival of the civilizing God
and a battle must be fought to establish
a livable world within that chaotic
world okay and usually that and often
that that the livable world will be made
from the cutting up literally cutting up
one of these primordial chaotic gods and
using the pieces as the building blocks
for the world okay and in some versions
of these stories the Giants and monsters
are then once the world is established
are then pushed out into the margins and
are seen as living on the very edges of
the world you know like the Atlas
Mountains that acted as a barrier all
the way to the ocean in the military
Mediterranean world in the Bible we have
this image of gog and magog a reference
to these nomadic tribes up in the north
but them also strangely at the same time
being like these demons and according to
legend these tribes were blocked out of
the world by Alexander the Great
sealed up north let's say by these
Caspian gates these you know this image
of these huge iron doors and Alexander
the Great would have built to keep these
hordes out of the world and then at the
end of the world these devouring
tribes will be let out and would descend
upon the world to consume it okay so see
once again this relationship between the
edge you know adore wall limit and the
end the end of the world where those
limits fall apart so you can see that as
you move away from the center let's say
the center of space and the origin of an
identified epic or or humanity one moves
away from order to chaos from city or
the garden out to decomposition
fragmentation of the city or else to
wild nature a form of wilderness being
prey to the beasts of the field and
coming finally with the limit of
manifestation which was this unending
ocean okay
I've talked about this and I've actually
written quite a bit about this before
and so if those if some of you want more
details on this I'm going to link to
some more talks and some articles that I
gave that touch upon this structure on
the structure before okay
these patterns are a little bit
difficult to assimilate so I'm hoping
people are starting to see what I'm
talking about okay so in the Bible
there's this flood the flood of Noah at
the end of the lineage of Cain which is
a return to the primordial ocean as I've
said which was where which was there
before the world existed but the ark Eve
but the Ark in that story is a smaller
version is a contained version of that
larger event and so the ark is a
container full of animals okay it's a
container which is made out of that
which my own garments of skin are made
and a an image of my limit of my death
right but also the animals which precede
the creation of man in the creation
narrative so you can see how there are
these embedded self-replicating
structures within the story patterns
within
within patterns the water proceeds and
surrounded the world just as animality
precedes and surrounds man okay so I
think I repeated myself enough so
hopefully this is under sufficiently
understandable there are some subtleties
in there that I haven't mentioned and
and hopefully I can touch on them as I
lay this out okay so so this structure
helps us to see how in ancient societies
the men the human were usually those who
were calling themselves that usually
those who are speaking that is we
whoever we are are the humans we are the
men and further and further we move away
from ourselves we come to encounter
Barbaria you know barbarians barbarian
is someone who barks like a dog we
encounter people whose humanity I can
see with more and more difficulty as I
move away from myself I mean either
pretty understood concept so so you can
imagine the Chinese considered
themselves the kingdom of the middle and
around them they put up walls to stop
the chaotic nomads from pouring in okay
so the Greek cities had the umbilicus
Mundi they had the navel of the world
and they were surrounded by more and
more foreign barbarians right
Mesopotamians where this balance between
the two rivers etc etc so in this guise
the foreigners are like dogs they appear
as beasts and monsters right and we see
that in the ancient description of the
Far Away races a kind of breakdown of
categories where the further you get
away from whoever it is that's speaking
the more the races that are talked about
are fantastical and impossible and in a
kind of chaotic
manifestation okay so there was you know
a kind of constant informal capacity to
dehumanize those that are far away to
see them advances as decadent right as
animalistic right this is something
which is universal and this capacity was
not just a geographical structure but
it's also a social structure and so this
capacity to dehumanize can happen on a
social ladder and the bottom of the
ladder being akin to the land far away
from the center let's say or the lower
caste especially the slaves are seen are
less than human and this is heightened
by the fact that slaves are often taken
from vanquished foes far away now this
capacity that we have to dehumanize is
really universal and you can see it
we're its ugly head as much in Western
colonialism as you can see it and how
you know the Irish were demonized by the
English how the Jews were often
demonized by Christians but also how the
the Tutsis were DeMuth demonized by the
Hutus or or how in central Africa the
pygmies for example are often seen by
the Bantu tribes that are there as being
less than human and here in North
America through the recent history of
slavery will of course seen many
horrifying examples of this where you
know that this relationship people make
between Africans and apes and all these
types of of relating other races to and
animals in one way or the other but we
also have to we have to remember right
that this echoes in a way our own human
structure with our animal aspect as a
kind of periphery on our edges
representing our own passions or or our
own more or less repressed excesses
let's say so it's a strange way it's
often the case that the foreigners not
only we're see
as less human less intelligent but we're
also seen as a kind of mirror onto which
to project our own periphery let's say
our own dark sides and so the foreigners
are all often represented as decadence
you know as giving in to all kinds of
strange passion
they're often hyper sexualized hungry
greedy scheming you know tyrannical
cannibal incestuous vessel you name it
whatever dark tendency we can find on
our edges we're able to throw on these
further and further away groups now now
the thing about experiencing the four
and of the place where our dark passions
are projected is something which can be
we can be disgusted by or maybe fear or
despise but it can also be something we
revel in okay and the best example I
like to show is how in the beginning of
the 20th century because of European
colonialism all these statues and art
objects from Africa and other colonized
countries started to pour into Europe to
the Europeans these statues appeared as
truly monstrous in with pointed teeth
and scarification and most people were
somewhat taken aback as these statues
presented traits and aesthetic
categories which were so far from our
visual standards that they they broke
our visual cues right but others saw in
these statues and art you know a kind of
animal passion a kind of sexual energy
and so Picasso for example use African
masks in that way placing them on
prostitutes in his Demoiselles d'Avignon
and the Dada artists would prance around
naked to the sounds of drums you know
whipping up a kind of frenetic sexual
energy and making chaotic gibberish
noises but but of course for the African
cultures themselves the
statues and masks you know and these
forms were rather means to reinforce
their own stable and very strict sexual
taboos and practices and we're not in
any way revolutionary in the way the
Europeans used them you know it was
their appearance as misunderstood forms
objects adrift without meaning that
could lead Europeans to you know
projects into them whatever was lying in
their own dark corner okay
there's also another way to dehumanize
the foreigner and that is to see them as
more than human sometimes imaged as
spirits or ghosts or even as kind of
metahuman exemplars let's say so for
example that's how the Roman historian
Tacitus played up the German people who
were for the Romans barbarians played
them up at being superior to his own
people in his famous book Germania or
how even today people would think you
know some people think that anything
formed be it Buddhism or shamanism is a
kind of foil on our inadequacies you
know having everything that we lack I
mean it's of course as easy for
something far away and unknown to
contain everything we hate and despise
and it is for it to contain everything
we admire and idealize or you know see
it beyond us right I always say that
that if you want to get the extreme
version of this you just have to know
you just have to look at how people
represent extraterrestrials in our
culture you know either
there are these you know demonic
invading chaotic beings or they are
these hyper perfect you know technical
technically accomplished you know kind
of super beings so those two extremes
exist in our
in our descriptions of those things that
are far away even those that are beyond
you know there are human experience but
what happened in the in the story realm
of our of our existence let's say and so
the these often these more than human
forms let's say or these two high forms
can appear sometimes this kind of
vengeful spirits you know in Europe we
had the Huns in the Mongols which were
seen by Europeans as this is fire the
scourge of God coming down from the
north you know to to punish us for our
sins like say or basically you know
every single novel by Stephen King you
know where some Native American spirit
comes to wreak vengeance upon our
society so although this this capacity
to dehumanize into spirits or foils
might seem to contradict the first way
to dehumanize but these are just really
two sides of the same coin
you see in the story of Genesis there is
a second part of this idea of chaotic
waters and it's called a separation of
the waters and so apart the waters are
separated to make space for the world
and end and then there's the waters
above and then there's the waters below
and this is of course one of the most
misunderstood aspect of the Genesis
story but it has something to do with
how chaos or change or potentiality can
like a like a turning wheel give ride
both to the lowest and the highest
States right and what is on top can flip
over and find itself below the best
example of course being the fall of the
angel especially the fall of State in
itself who is the highest angel but then
fell to the lowest state imaginable the
opposite is also true or Christ descends
into the pit descends into death but
then ascends into heaven and sits at the
right hand of the Father
okay
we'll see a little bit more about that
later I just start by saying that this
tendency to dehumanize foreigners in
this other sense is everywhere around us
as well you know from Russo's noble
savage to the African or South American
perception that Europeans were these
ghosts are these spirits coming down on
them this is of course a kind of spatial
definition of the foreign or the
stranger but there's also a temporal
version of the same structure and this
version is more difficult to understand
in some ways but I think it's primordial
to understand it if you want to be able
to see all sides of this question as I
said at the beginning that chaotic
waters appear as that which precedes
order precedes the manifestation of
logos so just as the foreigners on the
edge of the world are experienced as
versions of chaos so to the state of
affairs which was there before us
however we define that is also framed as
a kind of chaos a kind of projected
space for the subhuman or the demonic I
mentioned that this could be clearly
seen in the stories of generations of
God with the first generation of gods is
seen as chaotic and destructive you know
these Giants or whatever and unto which
the new order of gods imposes order
sometimes that which was there before is
pushed to the edge so the two types of
demonization let's say echo each other
but even when the two things might
inhabit the same space
the temporal relation of a founding or
origin or a state and identity or
religion whatever caste what was there
before and the same guys as the far away
foreigner so that was the case when you
know the Greeks replaced the Minoan
culture and kept a story of the cannibal
Minotaur how the the Celts became
demonized by the anglo-saxons and were
associated with
dark forest beer spirits and whatnot and
so to the Jews often took that role for
Christians the Native American took that
role for European settlers and like I
presented before the pygmies who were
the original peoples of sub-saharan
Africa who were subjugated by the bonjou
so that they became to the bond to a
strange mix of subhuman and terrifying
spiritual force so that the bond to both
just often not always but often look
down on them but also fear them because
they have these kind of strange chaotic
spiritual powers of nature and then just
as the spatial version they are moments
when what was there before you is see
not so much in lower turns but at being
higher more lofty than what you are
today and sometimes there is even a
strange revolutionary wheel right where
someone can reach back before the origin
of a people in order to replace the
current order so for example you know
when the Christians replace the pagans
they sometimes tended to demonize the
ancient God and put them and put in them
all perversion and excess but then when
the Europeans of the Renaissance and the
Enlightenment wanted to topple the
Christian Church they reach down if you
will you know reach down at what was
there before Christianity and attempted
to prop it up above Christianity make
paganism a new ideal upon which to
strive and then in their turn demonize
the church at backwards superstitious
dark and in its own way less and human
and you can see an echo here of how the
modernists like Picasso or the Dada used
for and art as a kind of weapon to
destroy the established order so the
same happen also with Egypt and then in
all these esoteric thinkers who by
projecting their ideal
this long lost civilization that he
could barely know anything about they
could lift that projection that
idealization of something before the
origin they could lift it up above
Christianity and Lord over Christian
civilization in that manner and this
tendency was also there in Protestantism
who wanting to topple Rome reached into
a mythic and little-known you know
Apostolic age before the conversion of
Rome so you see so many examples and you
see so many examples of that today
whether it be you know messianic
Christians who idealized Judaism who
people who idealized native religions
Scandinavian gods Judaism
I mean you name it anything that is long
loss can be propped up above what
represents order into here and now and
we all we all seem to be prone to this I
mean I am certain that a form of
fascination with eastern mystery you
know played a part in my own conversion
to Orthodoxy and God forgive me for that
if that part of my story I mean it's
very difficult to avoid these structures
even if we see them as a consequence of
the fall let's say as a symptom of our
broken incapacity to bring all things
together in a true and forthright manner
now one of the occurrences of the modern
age is that this process which which in
a way was a was organic and flexible you
know it wasn't something that was
clear-cut and so maybe a foreigner
wasn't fully fixed thing you know a
foreigner is a category like friend it's
not it's not an actual person it's a
category of of experience until maybe
the foreigner today could become a
friend tomorrow right in the same manner
that that which is before my origin
although I see it as dangerous for
example I might preserve it and protect
it nonetheless and we see how this
happened you know with Christian
Christianity's preservation of antiquity
by despite how it marginalised it and
even in how Christians protected and
preserved Judaism all the while
sometimes marginalizing it and
persecutors persecuting it okay but in
the modern age there's a kind of system
systematization of this process of
marginalization and dehumanization let's
say some of the things that happen in
the modern age that we merge this form
of jihyun ization with biology was
something that is fixed and that's
that's what we would call racism today
so for example if you were a jew that
converted to christianity in the year
1000 that meant that you were no longer
a jew you were a christian but in the
year 1800 that was no longer the case
your identity became biology and
unchangeable right and at the same time
the rather fluid relations between
people that existed in empires were now
set in stone with the creation of clear
borders and ethno nation-states and we
know what this led to so sadly the late
Middle Ages gave rise to regional and
occasional deportation of Jews for
example the modern age has led to
massive ethnic displacement deportations
of people and creations of ethnic
nation-states
India and Pakistan Turkey and Greece and
many more and there are arose forces
that not only wanted to get rid of
certain ethnic groups from their myths
but wanted to eradicate them altogether
from the face of the earth
and that was certainly new and a kind of
totalizing version of what before was a
more you know fluid process and we've
heard echoes of that recently haven't we
identity and space blood and soil
now there is a flip side to this which
is the system I systematize ation of the
other type the kind which is framed in
time and a kind of destruction of
identity and space it's in the ancient
world there was a tendency to
marginalize all that came before your
own origin with the idea of social
progress
the usual stop-gap process of seeing
chaos and the pre originated past became
a continual process where if each
incremental movement forward gave one
the right may the prerogative to speak
of those behind you as regressive
barbarian less intelligent and doomed to
the trash bin of history of course we
saw this for example in the French
Revolution where as the revolution
radicalized throughout the radicals of
yesterday could be the dangerous
conservatives of today and fit only for
the guillotine and we see the same now
where if when one does not agree with
the latest social fad of emancipation
one is immediately branded as a radical
right sexist racist transformed Nazi you
know and many of the feminists let's say
the early feminists of the 60s are now
seen as part of the problem and not with
the times to insult to attack to destroy
those that are not with the time is not
only possible but can be seen as a duty
to the future now I focus on the second
aspect because it's far more acceptable
in our society but but pay attention
because when you hear people speak of
those they do not agree with as a
regressive as stuck in the Middle Ages
implying without saying it that they are
somehow less intelligent and we've seen
a lot of this with Americans mocking and
disparaging southerner southerners on
which they were able to establish their
own you know
powerful identity we've seen it with
atheists mocking religious people they
see themselves as more forward in time
and less stuck in the past this is a
form of lessening of placing oneself
above and it is couched in social
Darwinism
just like the Nazis but instead of
racial differences it's rather an
emphasis on time on the progressive
evolution of complex organisms from
simple ones so what the so-called
progressive is invoking is that he as a
progressive as the one who is on the
cusp of this program of this this this
constant revolutionary progress is
closer to let's say evolved man and
further from the Apes that's it and it's
the same structure as comparing other
races to animals the same structure
which repeats and accelerates the
structure of dehumanization I've been
presenting since the beginning of this
where the chaotic waters are always that
which perceived my origin it in the same
structure which justifies abortion for
example and just because the progressive
version of dehumanization has become
acceptable in our culture doesn't take
away that it plays out the same pattern
in different guises so the first kind of
limiting a kind of identity based on
center and margin can lead one to saying
something like we're going to build a
wall the other let's say time based
identity can lead someone to saying
something like because it's 2015
[Music]
and use that argument to enforce you
know we're force whatever change that
person sees as moving towards the
constant progress of the human species
hopefully you can see that I am not
justifying any of this but rather I
think it is important to perceive the
scope this human tendency can have in
all of us that it is almost impossible
to ignore that if we look down upon
those who demonize far away foreigners
for example we at the same time might be
the exact type of people who didn't
demonize those who are regressive who
are behind us at the time so what is the
Christian answered and as I said
Christians have not been innocent of
this in any way but what would be the
truly Christian answer to this problem
because you see as although we can see
that we all engage in such thoughts that
we all catch ourselves which does
thought it with such a tendency to put
ourselves above others there is a
nagging part of us which strive for a
completeness a part of us which yearns
for wholeness so in a way I'm asking
what is the Christian answer to the fall
what is the Christian answer to
dehumanization I think in part it is to
plunge into it first of all we need to
see that Christ himself is both the
origin the logos which structures the
world and judges the world he is the
king who sits at the cosmic throne but
he is at the same time the accused
criminal who died on the cross outside
the city
right on the hill of the skull who was
abandoned by all betrayed by all by his
own people by his friends but also by
the foreigner so Christ is both the king
and the judge while at the same time
being the scapegoat so in order to reach
the the completeness the totality Christ
has to be both both in the inside the
standard the rule you know but also
drink the entire ocean of path take upon
him the entirety of flesh and death and
suffering so that he could be all in all
so - as Christians we are called to be
both little Christ in the world both
shaping and forming order out of chaos
called to be lights pillars in the world
preserving the integrity of the world
but we are at the same time called to
embrace suffering
embrace death to take on to see
ourselves as being the stranger the
foreigner in a foreign land those two
things at the same time no one said it
was going to be easy